[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of the first two episodes of the
new tv series on apple tv plus
severance now what's interesting about
this show it's created by dan erickson
who is someone who really doesn't have
much of a resume on imdb he's kind of
brand new to this it's exciting to have
a fresh
voice here doing a show and that he's
writing all these episodes is exciting i
also like that these first two episodes
are directed by ben stiller so it
already had me intrigued from the
trailer from the cast that's in this and
what's great about this show so far is
it has a very original concept at its
core here about having that
you're splitting yourself into two with
the work memories and the personal
memories and that you forget about it
when you get home at the end of the day
i really like it i like that it's a
blend of this black mirror vibe with a
lot of hitchcock influence and even of
recent times it reminds me a bit
especially the beginning of squid game
when we first meet helly here and she's
on the table and listening to this
mysterious voice now the actress of
helly is played by britt lauer who i've
always thought is a great actress i
really loved her in man seeking woman
that's a great underrated comedy show on
fx if you ever want to give it a chance
so i'm happy to see her getting more
work here and what really stands out is
the great lead performance by adam scott
who is always great but the character of
mark gives him a chance to shine his
real acting chops here because he does
such a good job of playing this guy who
when he's at work you know he's more
happy he's focused but there's like a
man dying inside on his facial
expression and that obviously comes out
when he gets out of work but he does a
good job of kind of showing little hints
of that just in his face alone when he's
at work and patricia arquette another
heavy hitter here is
great to have play this character of
peggy who is the boss at his job with
the silver hair and we get this nice
twist that she's also his neighbor in
the real world and what's really good
about this setup episode the first
episode is that it does a good job of
doing some non-linear storytelling here
and
seeing the same situations from
different perspectives and they do that
throughout the show they even do an
episode two more towards the beginning
so i like that they're giving good
balance of time to
our characters giving a little bit to
john to turtle's character irving but
mostly to obviously our main character
of mark played by adam scott but also to
heli played by britt lauer and what's
good about the character of helly for us
is she is the audience we are helly
right that starts from the beginning of
episode one we're thrown into this world
just like she is and she's the one we're
discovering and learning information
from so we relate most to heli and
asking questions in her perspective so i
like that they're shifting perspectives
through the show and not just sticking
on one one of my favorite moments in
episode one is the line by peggy
patricia arquette's character talking
about hell and she's like whatever
humans can imagine they can usually
create this is some of the best writing
of the show and if we're going to get
more of this as it goes on it makes me
excited to see what this
newer writer of dan erickson can do but
they timed out reveals really well on
this show and they're doing a good job
great mystery shows do is they give you
bread crumbs
always they're kind of satisfying your
quench for some answers but giving new
questions it's a nice balancing act
they're doing so far we're already
getting some answers by the first two
episodes and they already are giving you
some nice twists in the first episode
alone i like by the halfway point we get
this reveal that heli did give her
consent to come work at this company and
that's what's fascinating about this
show is that
you're seeing two versions of everybody
where the heli who is in work and the
heli who is the audi
you want to know now as the show goes on
as hell is trying to figure out too like
how did why did she agree to this why
did she agree to be severed and work
here that's what's so interesting about
this show i believe and letting it have
so many paths it can go down that could
be really interesting and then we get
another twist by the end of this just
first episode that patricia arquette's
character is also the neighbor of adam
scott's character mark and i like that
you know little things that you kind of
have to pay attention to that true
shortcuts character says at work that
her mom was an atheist but you know her
character the neighbor outside of work
says her mom was a catholic so there's
something going on there it's gonna get
reddit theories going which is good like
i always say too i love shows that
aren't based off a book like this
because then people can actually
theorize and not have to have the
answers already out in some kind of
writing and ben stiller here does a
great job directing i love his choice
too of these snowy exterior shots look
great but also how good he is at using
the camera to show
what each character is thinking and what
they're feeling and does a good job of
showing that just by these moments he
uses really intense extreme close-ups
and cutting back
to a medium shot
just to show again that transfer of the
triggering of going down the elevator
and those memories going away but they
do a good job of making this
personalized story especially this
character of mark and that you know this
appeal that your character would have to
get severed that you're going to work
eight hours a day you don't have to
think about your miserable grief you
have in the real world you know i think
a lot of people can relate to that and
it's like an extreme commentary on our
workplace and our work life and that's
what i'm getting from the show too is
there is some point of it where you
think about it and you look how this was
started this company and how they're
brainwashing these people and it makes
you think like how did office america
how did corporate america start in our
world so it's like an extreme version
but if you see how brainwashed we can be
and it's kind of a commentary on that at
least that's how i'm seeing it and also
what's up with his brother-in-law marx
uh just rubbing his foot in episode one
very very odd character i like to hear
the theories on what's his deal but
episode one great setup very intriguing
i'm gonna give that episode an 8.4 now
episode two i was like okay this is
gonna make or break like just from
watching episode i was like okay this
could be really good or could fall down
fast on its face but
no i was so impressed by episode two
which is again directed by ben stiller
and written by the showrunner dan
erickson every scene mattered here i was
on the edge of my seat the whole time
and it didn't throw away character
development either it all worked here
and it was also a visual treat the
music's really good in the show i love
the little piano score that keeps
running throughout it's got this little
piano theme that also works great in the
intro and this intro sequence felt fresh
original with adam scott's character of
mark i loved it seeing the two versions
of him in this really cool kind of like
3d art form but in this episode they're
also going to get people's theories
going and who are these characters
they're again giving these little bread
crumbs like i'm talking about where
there's this evil going on we're
learning more about as we go on but we
see this character of milchik who is an
awesome character he's very scary and
he's one of those characters though has
like a friendly exterior but you know
something awful is going on in his
interior and i like that he has this
line where he points like i love seeing
the sunrise on his face it's kind of i
guess their leader of this company lumen
that's on the wall so that's gonna be
interesting to see who even is playing
that character or if he's even still
alive and you know so much importance in
every single line in the show like this
and you see mark even mentions to helly
here it's important we don't meet on the
outside but we know mark's character in
the previous episode has met petey so
that was a good reveal in episode one
too that we know that petey is still
alive but he has
reversed the surgery of severing and
you're seeing how it's affecting mark at
work and that he's thinking more about
pd he doesn't want that picture of pd on
the desk anymore and then you see that
in this little like throw the ball and
talk about each other moment with the
employees he's getting too serious about
it and reflecting on
missing petey and what's going on with
pdz he's still alive and that's when
milchik's like that's enough and again
what i'm talking about with that you
know it's going to remind you something
happens in corporate where he then goes
and transfers the attention to the
melons that are in the yummy melons or
that even in episode one we got in the
head they gave him a nice gift card to
kind of just cover themselves when he's
outside of work and saying that was a
different cause of him hurting his head
and that he fell
very similar to what corporations do to
just keep people quiet and it's adding
these effects of horror here with john
turturro's character and that's the
stuff that's going to make your brain go
wild like what is going on and he's got
the black under his fingernails he's
seeing visions that are of black gooey
dozes off and then one of the crazy
sequences is when he is brought to the
wellness room we see christopher watkins
playing this character of bert who does
optics and design which we're definitely
going to learn more about obviously
because it's christopher walken so we
only get a little bit here but one of
the characters one of the employees
mentions that he is not a nice guy so
that's gonna be interesting to see
what the deal is with him but again with
john turturro who's doing this great
deserving which she's always great this
scene where he's put in this room with
this woman who's
reading him stuff about his audi that's
good facts you know the crazy part is he
can't respond he can't show any
favoritism towards any of those facts
any facts that make him happier he loses
points so really creepy stuff eerie
stuff and that also that eerie stuff
goes to the break room and that mark
takes a fall for heli here and this
break room we don't see what happens but
we hear
sort of what happens when petey reveals
it on the tape that they're just
apologizing and it's this brainwashing
that's going on that it's all his fault
and that he did wrong so it's gonna be
fascinating to know what's really going
on in these break rooms and whatever
parts of this company that we're again
we're only seeing
the severed department here and i like
that they've built a world that makes
sense
outside how people would react to this
company and that this company is
everywhere you know it's your soap it's
your food and that there's protesters of
it that don't trust severing and there's
something just bleak about this outside
world as it is in this corporation so
it's really exciting to watch and ben
stiller just shows off he has a nice
touch with symbolism too something
really stuck out to me a shot i love was
in episode one just with mark laying on
his couch and he's got only lit up the
fish tank in the two fishes you know
representing the two sides of mark and
more mystery too about these scary
numbers right like even one of the
characters is theorizing what they could
be doing but we don't know you know so
it's doing something significant when
they clean out the scary numbers and
little character details are so
important just here with mark and again
great performance by adam scott to do
these things so seamlessly but his hands
trembling when he's outside of work and
we see that pd is sick after even
removing this procedure from his body
but what is it causing these people to
do these side effects that we see with
irving and now we're seeing mark
trembling like it's obviously not good
for you but we know what's really
terrifying is that mark is housing petey
better this episode in his basement we
know his neighbor is his boss but we
don't know that much about her version
outside if she even is
severed so that's another debate we can
already have is she just putting a false
act on outside and keeping an eye on
mark but that's gonna be problematic
that pd's even that close to her because
she is dangerous but i was blown away by
episode two i mean
i don't remember last time i was so into
an episode of a show this is my favorite
type of show genre whatever you want to
call it i love something that's keeping
you hooked keeping your brain stimulated
but with great character great acting
great cinematography and really good
music and again it's that mystery just
wanted to come back this is definitely a
show where you wish you could actually
binge it but i'm happy we can talk about
each week so i prefer that anyway and
yeah i feel like everyone in this
episode is going to want to see episode
3 like now but i'm giving this episode a
9.5 i loved it and that really made me
now invested i cannot wait for the next
episode so let me know what you thought
of these first two episodes i'd love to
hear your thoughts i read every comment
try to respond as many as i can please
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
one of my reviews of severance i will be
covering every episode for sure and
please follow me at steve arley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and i'll see you next time